[Music]
all right now paulie
you know what time it is huh oh yeah
arch madness we got sean green and ryan
kramer from monkey night fight our
favorite thing to say here
monkey knife fight the sports gambling
podcast
uh you know i don't want to brag or
anything guys
uh but i kind of crushed it on all of my
super bowl bets
oh we got everything from the coin toss
to the color of the gatorade just saying
yeah as soon as as soon as the blue
gatorade got dumped my twitter
feed got lit up i'm just everyone i told
you
i told you blue gatorade you know burr
had it right
yeah you nailed it man and you were all
over you're all over your buddy brady
and the bucks and
man that was aggressive paul did you
hear that all over your buddy brady
gonna be that i just knew he was gonna
win it's my buddy now
oh god you're a brady backer and
i'm a married man i know passive
aggressive statements when i hear them
throw it under the bus a little bit all
over your body baby
okay god no i i mean
again great job and again not not coming
into the context
wouldn't i be all over him he's won six
out of nine now
seven out of ten you're making it seem
like i bet some 50 to one horse
i'm with you bill easy money easy money
kramer was on the bucks as well you guys
cleaned up man
i love it i love it what about uh what
about march madness i know we're on the
anything better
uh podcast but verzi anything better
than just watching
a [ __ ] ton of march madness games having
some action actually having the march
madness to talk about
listen i love a favorite and i'm
sticking to it because gonzaga is not
[ __ ] losing
i'm telling you this right now gonzaga
is undefeated they're gonna stay
undefeated
they're the best team in the country i
actually watched him play a little bit
um bill will tell you from experience of
our friendship
and many years of talking sports on the
phone
in hotel rooms in green rooms i can't
lay off a favorite
and if there was ever a favorite that i
had to stick with
it's the [ __ ] it's gonzaga so paul
loves the regular season what happens in
the regular season
in his world is what is going to happen
in the playoffs so if gonzaga beats some
division three team by 80 he
he he lost any i mean i i used to do i
used to drive me nuts back in the day
when he would talk about quarterbacks
that were
better than my buddy brady um
and i'd be like listen if you want
somebody to throw 500 yards in november
against the team that isn't going to
make the playoffs this is your guy but
if you want someone to win in january
i need wins in january so i march is
different
i'm already i i'm not saying i don't
know [ __ ] about college hoop but i can
already tell you just because somebody's
undefeated in the regular season
that that does not carry as much weight
as my striped friend here is trying to
tell you
no i mean yeah gonzaga has looked really
good but you're right
when these teams are undefeating the
regular season it's just
so much pressure leading up to
eventually
a letdown game i mean i like gonzaga to
maybe make it to the final four but
to win it all i i think it's a little
crazy i'm going with the team like
michigan
already got a couple tough losses out of
the way
you know now they they know what it's
like to lose they don't want that taste
in their mouth
and gonzaga they just seem to every year
we go through this rhyme with gonzaga
where
they look so good they dominate the
whack and then
tournament time they're in a minimal
security prison
okay if you play on tobacco road or
you're you're in the big ten i mean
that's like you know you got to make a
shank
fellas fellas wire to wire
it's over i'm i'm with you paul actually
i think
it's becoming popular to find a reason
to pick against
the best team in the country and we've
seen this in every other sport sean
the best team has come home and raised
the trophy at the end of the year so i
think it happens again
uh paul and i are uniting against you
you know what that doesn't saga coach
it's that gonzaga coach's time
okay that dude has been knocking on the
door for a while he's finally got the
team to do it
um and i saw them completely paul i'm
taking that action
yeah he's not watching looking uh
paul and cramer's actions i'm not
tagging to win it all
[Music]
i'll take that all day i'll root for him
because i love i would love to see
somebody out of the whack win at all
but like dude you you come on man
this is like you you've got bombs fights
here you're undefeated playing a bunch
of who
are they playing out there i i expected
i expected to hear versi
you know being being right there in the
jersey area big east basketball talking
about georgetown
the fact that patrick ewing won it as a
player and as a coach
cinderella's story but you're going
chalk with gonzaga mercy
yeah i mean listen when i watch them
play i the the rebounding the big guys
down there like
and here's the other thing i saw gonzaga
get tested they were getting tested by
uh i think it was byu
byu was testing them byu was beating
them
okay byu yeah byu was beating them
though and byu was beating them pretty
good and people are going oh this is the
game that gonzaga gives it up
and you know what like the [ __ ]
champions that they are
chanting that at the game paul nothing
scares the whole player when he hears
mormons chanting
like champions the zags [ __ ] want it
like the champions that they are
they [ __ ] came back they went to utah
granted they were playing a bunch of
[ __ ] white kids from byu
but you know they don't get a lot you
have a gig of gonzaga coming up my god
this is crazy
that they're going to win they're
talking about coach k they're going to
win it man
they're going to win it i'll put [ __ ]
five honey on it i'll put what do you
want
i'll take that send that this way buddy
oh wow
you take yeah but so you're taking the
easy way out you're going to just pick
one
of 30-something teams i mean who's going
to win any way out paul is knowing that
you're all over it
i'm telling you fade the mush it doesn't
get it
you're pushing the bronx tear up you
think come on kryptonite
come on the huge favorite who won
everything yeah i didn't i'm i'm fading
uh i'm faded just because we were on the
same side in the super bowl and it
didn't work out for us take it the
favorite
bill who do you like any any teams i
know you're not
my team i got three teams that i like
that i root for
michigan kansas and uh
duke so out of the three of the ones who
had the best year is michigan
i like their uniforms i'm just kidding i
just i'm like
i'm a housewife here dude i haven't
watched enough uh
i saw some kid on tennessee throw it
down though oh yeah there was
there's some elbows going yeah
i'm going michigan yeah
to the victor's [ __ ] zaga they didn't
play anybody
pale hail to michigan yeah
500 bucks up for z yes well i don't know
if you saw bill but uh juwan howard
their coach he was getting into it i
always
i always got to support a team whose
coach isn't afraid to get scrappy
start yelling at the other coach and we
it's it's been hilarious in these
coveted times
where the the coach is wearing the mask
until
he needs to pull it down and yell right
in the mic in the
coat you know in the rest you can almost
you can almost see the droplets
coming out of it you're gonna hear my
point and take this virus
that's how mad i am at you it's like why
you didn't wear these masks or the the
coaches who wear the creepy clear mask
it's just so unsettling and they still
again just pull it down
any time they need to yell completely
defeating the purpose
of the mask that happened last night the
knicks had a heartbreaker against the
seventies oh
yes tom thibodeau's [ __ ] mask
was on his chin his shirt was out his
boxer shorts
his [ __ ] boxer shorts were over his
[ __ ] dress his button down
and he just it was like corona didn't
matter anymore it's like yeah it's like
that's not a call
well probably make him wear the best if
they're just gonna pull it down to
to yell at these refs interesting little
side notes six of the refs already have
been replaced for march madness
one tested positive and the other six
were went out to lunch for them
bill i know you're not afraid to be a
conspiracy theorist at times
any uh any shenanigans potentially with
the refs here
i just don't there's no upside for it
for college basketball they own those
kids
they don't pay them i think when you get
to the pros
like uh i mean i i think if they were
going to be shaving points or doing
something nuts like that i don't think
that they would
get rid of a whole fleet of referees i
mean it's it's it's a little too
obvious yeah i don't i don't like it i
like
the uh there was only one mobbed up ref
in the nba in the 2000s i love that
tim donaghy was a solo actor no no one
else was involved
donaghy i i listened to some interviews
the guy's hilarious he
he admits to being involved in these
scandals
but he insists that the games he bet on
he didn't
adjust the way he called the game which
is the craziest thing
like he admit that he was involved with
the mob admitted everything else but
tried to still keep some ref integrity
there like dirtbag but i got a line okay
exactly i i just happened to
[ __ ] kids
[Laughter]
so wait a minute though wait a minute
let's real quick bill let's get to this
bet
so you're gonna so 500 i'm putting all
the 500 you're just saying someone's
going to take them out
you're getting a little easier there oh
that's not the kind of that's not that's
not who i am
how long have you known me first of all
i'm not taking 500 of your hard-earned
money
all right so what are we gonna do and a
cigar
okay okay and before i i before you take
your first bite you have to say
whoever loses have to be like insert
name here
god damn it you were right you've never
been more right in your life and it is
an
honor for me to pick up this check and i
will buy dessert also
i i'm just saying michigan is going to
go further than gonzaga oh
that's probably even money and and bill
is talking about being married you know
it's a classic married guy thing the bet
is he just wants to hear someone else
say they're right
i can't i that's as a married guy that's
my fantasy no longer
you know two chicks at the same time
just the wife to go you know what after
all this
you were right moving on i don't want to
be heard i just want to be heard
listen to me sweetheart did you love me
we got some uh we got some awesome games
here again monkey knife fight
that's the place to go they got college
basketball march madness
tournament bets we got prop bets for
these players again
use that promo code burr get a free five
dollar
uh play and a hundred dollar or 100
percent deposit match
up to 50 bucks using the promo code
monkeyknifefight.com
the first four game again there were 64
teams not enough
for all the action had a crowbar four
more teams in
kicking things off thursday night ucla
michigan state
pretty good historic matchup uh you know
two kind of like powerhouses
not great years for either teams ucla
kind of coming in cold
tip off 657 on the east coast we got two
player props
more or less on these points michigan
state forward
aaron henry 16 and a half points kramer
i'll let you kick it off over under
more or less 16 and a half uh yeah i
mean he's
he's the nba prospect too so if you're
if you're an nba guy this guy's gonna be
playing in the league and i think if you
like michigan state you like
this you like henry to score over 16 and
a half points sean as you know
i like ucla in this one so i'm going to
take the under
oh okay you're going under versi what
are you uh where are you at here
michigan state forward
16 and a half points first uh this is
actually the late game
on thursday night getting the tournament
started
you know um i like i like ucla too
so um but so 16 and a half points he's
got he's got to get 17.
yep i'm gonna take the under
okay like it lock it up he's taking the
under
now now he's now he's going anti-chalk
burr what are you doing here over under
16 and a half points aaron henry pretty
good forward for michigan
the under then bersie said under so i
don't know here i'm with you i'm
i was in my head not knowing you know
who this kid is
hey i got all the under right of the
super bowl huh
all the unders of the yards that i said
passing from mahomes and brady i got
right when i said the under for the
super bowl
you sound like a community college right
now trying to be number one in something
your niche number one pamphlet school in
the rhode island region
we have the coldest coca-cola in any
cafeteria
the best bikini valley area the best
pool vending machine
in the break roof yes i would say that
i'm thinking this kid who i've never
seen play
who i've already forgotten his name this
is aaron henry
aaron henry i would say that he's
feeling the pressure
normally and he'd be a little tight on
this first game however these kids grew
up with instagram
right they know what it's like to hit
their marks
say it be funny they've had handled
criticism and all of this crap
everybody's all one and done now
everybody's sick with it i believe is
what the kids say i'm gonna go positive
trip all right just so we have some [ __ ]
talk about
i'm going i say this kid scores 21. ooh
i like that i'm going over he's he
showed up big
when they played michigan had a nice
game uh ucla's defense is kind of
falling apart and
big ten they actually played their
conference tournament
in this bubble site for the tournament
he's used to the rims
he's not a he's dialed in i'm i'm going
over 16 and a half
moving over to the ucla side and i'm i'm
sure i'm going to mispronounce this
guy's name
johnny giuseng uh guard for the
ucla bruins 13 and a half points
more or less paul i know you're on ucla
you going more here
yeah 13. he had that yeah yeah i'm gonna
take over i'm gonna say he gets 14.
yeah just over all right i'm with you
i'm going over even though i'm on
michigan state for the game lay in two
i do think this is gonna be a little
more high scoring than we're used to for
a uh
for a big ten pac-12 game kramer pac-12
shows up for the tourney the kentucky
transfer has a huge game
goes over scores 30 sean i'm saying he
scores thirty
all right well you can do some uh you
can do some adjusted lines on the monkey
knife fight if you really think he's
gonna go off i think they have some
adjusted stuff here and you can add in a
bunch of players and go like
kramer just got me yo you just got me
when you said kentucky transfer i just
literally saw you here
i just saw the bed i'm doing when you
said you're touching myself
yeah paul perked up he's like are you
talking about a blue blood pressure
i got nothing you're the favorite action
i got nuggets some chalky action coming
your way
bill what about what about you man uh i
think this kid tries to hang for a
little while
don't know who i don't even remember his
name johnny
you know i write a lot of scripts so
here's my script this kid tries
his kid tries to hang with them in the
first half
he gets about eight i think he can eke
out another six
in the second half but this kid i'm
telling you who's going to rise to the
occasion of michigan state that i've
never heard of
he's go he's going to run away in the
second half i think that that's what
happens they both go over
well then and he's going on that hero's
journey for the
screenwriters out there i i do
appreciate bill's honesty of just saying
i've never heard of this guy but and he
can still hit a talking point
yeah and and just kind of shows you
these talking heads even though they're
pretend
did you see uh the clip of paul pierce
talking about the sixers
and they he he thought they they lost by
and he was given this whole take on the
highlights and they had won by 36.
she shows you how tuned out some of
these guys are oh dude paul pierce when
you watch him he's a good dude but
that guy just is [ __ ] checked out man
yeah the guy who's phoned in a couple
gigs i
i know the look uh when i see it all
right i've never seen a guy give a [ __ ]
less
about a post game than paul pierce ever
yeah look man that's like an astronaut
getting excited that someone else is
sitting in the rocket
yeah you tell what's going on with him
right now
you know he's uh making sure there's no
holes in the suit
yeah but give it to the nurse at some
point does anybody care
[Music]
he's already been there he's not gonna
give a [ __ ] all right
florida versus kramer you're virginia
tech hokies right now hokey's laying one
the uh player props we're going to talk
about friday
uh east coast 12 a 12 15 tip trey
mon the guard for florida his uh his
over under sitting at 17 and a half
kramer i know you're uh you're a hokey
die hard are you are you taking the
under here
listen the former five-star recruit is
starting to show up in a big way uh
after going under this total four
five times in a roshan he's gone over
the last five games
obviously end of the season tournament
time the cameras are bright he's going
to try to do a lot himself here i think
he goes over
okay he's gonna he's gonna press maybe
but getting a lot of shots up i
think he's finally coming into his own
as they like to say versi
uh florida sec country training
you're going under 17 and a half i'm
with you so i
i think this is going to be a good game
the spread reflects that but 18 points
against this
virginia tech defense which isn't
amazing but isn't like
isn't bottom barrel i'll say this i
think 18's a lot kramer's the only one
well taking over so far virginia tech i
think he gets there even if they're down
by a
lot it's kind of like the football
analogy if the quarterback is gonna
throw for a lot of yards either way it's
kind of the way they they've been
playing so yeah i'm going over
burr what where are you at with this one
treymon
i feel like florida's a sunnier state so
you can play basketball year-round
so these kids are out there playing
defense and that humidity you get them
inside an air conditioning
they're going to shut this kid down
what a relief central air
they're gonna be running downhill the
whole game yeah it's
it's not no humidity in indianapolis at
least not this time of year i mean we
literally
don't know man it is muggy you got to
adjust the dry heat you know
it's it's dry heat keve aluma
and and again kramer you can correct
there you go 14 and a half points
virginia tech forward i'm gonna start on
this guy i'm going
over here again i florida's defense has
kind of fallen apart a little bit late
they've really killed me on some bets so
i'm i'm on virginia tech for the game
i i think illuma getting 15 is doable
here
graham are you co-signing completely
co-signed i'd say i think the uh the
monkey knife fight
folks are fell asleep with the wheel
here his usage has been incredible
lately
i'd be very surprised if he doesn't go
over calling out the uh monkey i mean i
fight uh quanks i am calling
uh wrong number here he goes over are
you with him versi
i am because he's he's so into the team
and he knows the team
so well he said that he said that with
so much confidence
that i'm taking that yeah yeah you gotta
you gotta trust the guy who's got the
inside scooper where are you at
over under 14. hard to go against ryan's
confidence but
you know the fact that jersey was
enamored by it i just got to go against
it i gotta go against it sean by the way
i love how your background looks like a
foot locker the day after christmas
because nobody wanted the eagles jerseys
and everything else was sold
there was 92 rest of soul by the way
you got a media i've got a meeting
that's all we got is what's up
you can call it a foot locker sale but
you can't go out my boy reggie white
minister defense oh sorry i'm sorry i
didn't know that was right
no i said rest his soul rest his soul
but that's old school right there
yeah yeah come on that's my entire
childhood i do have a i have a bill
bergie custom jersey on the way
to hang up next to my chuck bed and eric
which uh
you know talking old school from
bethlehem pennsylvania
yeah my favorite part i've been able to
find that was a classic nfl clip
oh yeah we talked about that when you
were calling about
the game [ __ ] that guy just like oh
my god
oh man he did i shook his hand at a uh
youth awards banquet and it it looked
like he had
it had gone in like a juicer his his
pinky was like 90 degrees
and he just had this hand is like oh my
god
yeah ben eric hall of famer all right
last game we're gonna get to this one
another should be a classic here
syracuse who a lot of people arguing
maybe not deserving to be in the uh
tournament especially at an 11 seed not
having to play in
going up against san diego state the
aztecs
round one late night uh 6 40 on the
east coast buddy baeheim of course his
dad
is the coach i've been all in a buddy
baeheim
the kid is just shooting lights out 31
point game against virginia
16 and a half way too low all in buddy
baeheim kramer
you've been making fun of me for my love
affair with buddy mayheim and the
syracuse orange
are you go are you brave enough to go
under at 16 minutes
two true statements buddy is a dog's
name yes
also as a youth coach myself
youth girls soccer if i make the
playoffs like
like we see with jim you bet your ass
i'm playing my kids the entire goddamn
game
so he's gonna take all the shots buddy
bam goes over
versi versey where are you at with buddy
beyheim
yo this dude kramer i wish you coached
my you just have the knowledge that
if i like it's like everything you say
i'm just like i think this kid's got
[ __ ] together like i think that you know
a lot of stuff and i do like the fact
that this kid this is buddy behind's
first tournament or no
no no but this is this is his first
storm of playing many
minutes he he wasn't he wasn't getting a
ton of action on their on their previous
tournaments he said
i think he goes it's 16 and a half is a
great number but
you know what i think he chucks them up
i think he chucks him up to
you know presses old man and show people
it's uh buddy bayham time
it's 17 points for the kid
and and that is a i i know you're not a
uh version you're not a gambling tout
but that is a that is right in tool kit
number one of the gambling town
this is a great number this is a great
number gives yourself
a lot of wiggle room as a guy who's
giving out a bunch of bad picks if you
start out by complimenting the numbers
yeah give yourself some have no idea how
numbers are created
so they get very impressed when you talk
about the number as if you know this
oh wow that's very important shout out
to them great job over a monkey knife
fight
burn go either way yes yes
it'll all depend on who shows up do you
guys want to see a great gambling movie
watch owning mahoney
i'm trying to get through it it's done
so well as far as philip seymour hoffman
um just the uh oh yeah well i probably
shouldn't say that on a gambling website
it's so it's a feel-good movie where he
uh he wins every time
um all right but as far as buddy bowham
is that his name
beyond but yeah let me tell you
something buddy there's only room
for one bb in this entertainment
business and you're looking at them
i'm taking the under i say they shut you
down
buddy lock it up going what is the name
of a stock car driver
buddy baker right oh another another bb
i thought it was just the dog name
baseball player buddy bell
not a basketball player until he shows
up and scores more than 17 and a half
which will not happen
lock it up on the under and don't worry
most gambling movies end like uncut gems
so it's it's cool
another sunny day movie i i mean
you know that's how you know i have a
problem you watch that movie not gonna
spoil the end but uh
kind of a rough ending and just leaving
the theater i'm like i got to
figure out how he got that seven team
and i got i got to get me one of those
uh stones that stone was good luck man
what was that movie with um what was the
movie with pacino and mcconaughey
where mcconaughey was like his guy two
for the money two for the money the
brand
the money the whole point of that movie
was it's basically after all the [ __ ]
they went through
he goes it's a coin toss with the spread
it's literally a coin toss
it was one of the great montages in
cinema history of
mcconaughey lifting weights while like
reaching over and picking games against
the spread
it's an all-timer uh as far as hilarious
oh my god that's [ __ ] hilarious well
dude you know you only have abs once in
your life if you're lucky to ever have
them so you might as well show them if
you guys show them if you got them
that's what i say
hey you can't yeah i can't blame the
guys god he got him from all those uh
all those late night bongo sessions matt
mitchell
is the forward for the san diego state
aztecs
15 and a half points oh
again i'm on cues here to win the game
i'm going under
again maybe i'm blind to just supporting
buddy beyheim because my dog's named
buddy and
i'm all in but uh i i think their their
defense a little better than they're
getting credit for cramer
are you over under matt mitchell 15 and
a half points
matt mitchell as you know sean we
adopted san diego state to this podcast
yes so we are gals
i am sticking with that our gals and
matt mitchell
junkyard dog he shows up i think he has
a nice game hits some threes
gets over this 15 and a half point total
versi
where yeah kramer's over i'm under you
seem to be team kramer
but uh where are you at matt mitchell 15
and a half
under under
i kind of let him as an interviewer
you're not supposed to do you saw five
reds in a row and he's like i'm going
black
it's good classic roulette strategy uh
all right bill matt mitchell 15 and a
half i know you've been breaking down
his game film
uh in the offseason what are you doing
even though san diego state had a
basketball team
but the football team's been making some
noise and i think that they're uh
they're gonna feed off of that
and this kid's going to go over 15 and a
half
should not play much though because it's
a great number
it's a great number should be noted he
did play well in the simulated march
madness we created last year when march
madness got cancelled so
if that was a a foreshadow any harbinger
for things to come
all right that'll do it for the
tournament talk presented by monkey
nightfight
head over to monkeyknifefight.com daily
fantasy sports for the rest of us use
that promo code burr
get the five dollar game the free play
and a hundred percent deposit jose
go gonzaga yeah
he's on zags i've kramer's on the zags
bur and i
i got a prop for you paul right here
there it is
there it is we've been staying on the
winning train i won the last time you
bastard what are you talking about
gonzaga train
uh undefeated that's right all right
sorry
all right guys yeah the guy gets one
gatorade color right it's he's the
[ __ ] kid no no no
from coin toss to gate paul if you did
what i did
you would have had jordan ones with your
picks on the side of them the [ __ ] are
you talking about
i really want all right that's it thank
you guys hi guys
thank you so much